I think data should be banned
I think that uh as far as a national
security threat I kind of agree I'm not
into Banning stuff generally like I'm
it's different when you have your enemy
brainwashing your your citizens I mean
that's a different situation I agree
with you I'm not into Banning I I think
that we people jump to Banning way too
quickly there's a difference when it is
you know you're you're Banning someone
in your own country from doing something
are you stopping a company from doing
something if it is an adversary who
wants a world domination that's when you
have to say Okay this is different I
don't like it's not only an adversary
like they literally we just had a couple
uh
police stations that the CCP was running
we had well yeah the FBI arrested a
couple uh Chinese Nationals that had
basically are policing the Chinese in
America that I mean look that's
International or that's the you know
National sovereignty violation